driving for me is a stressful experience
anyway but that's probably because
i've spent most of my time driving in
thailand
oh man um because i i've never actually
drove so much in the uk because
like i grew up in brighton and then
london for my job so
i've never needed to be in a place where
i drive frequently
until i move to bangkok and my god
driving in just southeast asia in
general it's just
nothing like driving in japan or driving
in the uk or anything like that
so let me let me describe what it is
like driving in
one of these kinds of countries okay so
in thailand we don't have road rules
we have road suggestions that's that's
that's kind of
so we technically have rules but whether
people follow them or not
is up to the individual driver seems
like a mario kart with like a lot more
death yeah oh it is basically so
like you know you know how you change
lanes there's like a system for example
changing lanes
right you signal and then the person
like whether
backs off yeah the person backs off
whatever like whoever has the right of
way
the right of way in thailand goes okay
we're going to play this game of chicken
okay so imagine imagine i want to change
land or someone wants someone else wants
to change lane
and there's a car just like behind them
or like in the same lane
so the person's gonna start changing
lanes and either
one person backs off or the person
changing lane backs off
or we're gonna crash and so there's
there's
there's no rule to say who has to back
off right so one of them's going to back
off or you're going to crash
so it's basically who has the bigger
balls to like not give way
man yeah yeah exactly exactly dude it's
wild
i think like thailand looks scary this
other country is even worse i think
there's like um
i think in saudi arabia the number one
course of death is car accidents i
wouldn't be surprised
it's just crazy because i don't think
any other country it's even up there i
mean i went to the philippines a couple
of years ago to go to see aki's family
and we had to drive through manila
and that was one of the most terrifying
things ever because not only is there no
lanes and it's the same thing like it's
just
whoever gets in there first but there's
also people
just on the road just in the middle of
the road across
the worst thing is like the people in
the middle of the road who have just no
fear of death
and then motorcycles as well motorcycles
are like the [ __ ]
like annoying housefly that you that you
just can't like like [ __ ]
swat away but they're always there and
you always need to be
aware of them like driving in bangkok
you just have to like
you just have to master ultra instinct
they just every driver just needs to
master oh you just have to be like
rain man basically [ __ ] men turned on
that's why they can all drive
they go like like the [ __ ]
observation hockey like permanently
turned on when you're driving it's not
and it's not just a motorcycle either
it's like a mo
it's like one it's like a motorcycle
that's normally for like max two people
that
somehow have like eight people on it and
i'm just like
what like sometimes there's just a
motorcycle and there's just like the
the entire family on the motorcycle plus
the show first as well
it's like a clown car with a motorcycle
that just stressed me out so [ __ ]
much
like it's funny because bangkok living
in bangkok you you often take motorcycle
taxis even though in any other country
you would not take it and i describe
bangkok as like the only place i've been
to in the world
where i will willingly risk my life
every day going on a motorcycle taxi
so i can save myself from sitting in an
hour of traffic oh my god that's the
kind of that's the kind of city
it is during rush hour um and that's
just given me
a huge i wouldn't say fear of driving
but just every time
like i think about driving it just gives
me a cold sweat like huh
i gotta get back on that road man or
you've just like perfected your like
dodging technique
you got hit in the uk by some [ __ ] oh
really yeah yeah i got
so we were on i was driving uh to
we we have like a yearly house party
where a lot of my friends in the uk
catch up
and i was sitting in the car with um
alan my editor um alex allen's
girlfriend
sydney and d revelhouse and
um so we were we were on like a country
roads
and we had just like there was a car in
front of us so we just stopped and i
i like did like a kind of like a sudden
stop yeah because in front of us
like did did a very quick stop and then
d
was about to say nice driving guns and
as he was as
like as like the sound was leaving his
mouth
boom a [ __ ] car just like
just like tail ends my car and it
[ __ ] destroys my car
jesus and and
like like my car is [ __ ] totaled and
the car in front of us has the audacity
to be like yo
this was your fault by the way when are
you paying up and the car behind us
was like so so uh during the interview
when the police came we
we called the police we got you know
everyone everyone got like checked up in
an ambulance
and apparently he just he was going like
60 or 70 down a country road
and uh he just had his eyes off the road
he was like yeah i just took my office
my eyes off the road for a second and uh
who
who knew a car could creep up on me in
uh one second oh yeah
it's it's terrifying the country roads
like i learned to drive in london but i
also drove a lot in wales but like
those roads in wales are scary because
they're all like thick
trees right and really tight roads
especially like wales and then probably
in devon as well where we're in there
like there's like
[ __ ] trucks coming all the time on
these roads like a one way road or
it's it's two but when you get the big
trucks it's like you kind of might as
well be at once
yeah like so sometimes like you're going
like and they're normally 60 because
they're they're national
national speed limits 60 miles right
yeah yeah and then they'll just be like
trucks coming and you really have to
like [ __ ] i feel like truck drivers
in
every country are like they don't give a
[ __ ] because why would they
they win every time yeah if i had to
rock the destroyed paper
of course i'm going to pick rock they're
like they're like the jocks in the
school hallway right it's like you have
to move out of the way because they're
not gonna move
um yeah i mean that that was the only
car crash i've been in but there's been
many many close calls as you can
probably imagine in bangkok like
the health and safety in bangkok
especially on the roads
is very worrying how does an ambulance
get to you
if you i've wondered i wanted that exact
same question during the
shower motorcycle you can i guess you
just gotta [ __ ] bleed out on the road
right because
what's even what's even scarier right is
the taxi drivers in bangkok
because it's such a roulette wheel okay
so for one you'd expect
one of some one of the most dangerous
cities to drive in
to have a lot of like safety measures on
the public transports right
so most taxis you go in the back and
they there's no seatbelts
some of my some of the closest
near-death experiences i've had
have been on a [ __ ] taxi because taxi
drivers they don't get paid the most as
well so
they work ridiculously long hours so i
remember this one time i was
i was uh i was i had a night out and we
stayed out till
about like 3 4 a.m drinking at uh some
izakio in like bangkok whatever and we
had to go home and so we get a taxi home
and
the good thing about driving back home
in like the middle of like 4 a.m
is it's it normally driving there takes
two hours
but when there's no traffic it takes 30
minutes that's kind of like that's kind
of like the time you add on
when you don't factor in traffic right
but we're getting
so me and c it's me and sydney and we
get in this taxi and
this guy this guy just seems really
quiet and then he's
we get to the highway and he's doing
like [ __ ]
80 to 100 miles an hour on this on on
the freeway right
and then um sydney's like sydney's like
asleep in the taxi
uh so it's just me and it's complete
silence and then
he's just he just starts like swerving a
bit he just you know you know that thing
where
where you wake up yeah you're like whoa
whoa and
i'm like okay uh we we could have
crashed right there so i asked him uh
are you okay and he's like yeah it's i'm
completely good i've just been
up for like 36 hours i'm like pull over
hold on hold hold on a second and to
explain something about to explain like
something about thai culture we have
this thing called a mic and light
attitude which
the the closest translation is like a
joke
you know it's great when you're on
holiday you know because because the
reason
thailand's so great when you're on
holidays because everyone's so relaxed
you know it's
stress-free yeah but there are some some
situations where it's
very very not a very not in my opinion
situation and this was
this was one of those situations so i'm
asking him uh
are you okay you sure you don't want to
pull over we can get another taxi he's
like
might be like my might be like and i'm
like bruh this is a very not my
situation right now that we're in i've
been next to him the whole time like
slapping his cheeks
no i i i literally i was actually in the
back seat
no seatbelt by the way this taxi did not
have a seat belt
and this guy just i told him to slow
down and he goes okay i'll slow down so
he goes from 100 miles an hour to 80
miles an hour i'm like
bro get here like brilliant brilliant
but uh
everything is not mine yeah yeah he's
like
and like every every five minutes he
would just like i could see him not him
off nodding off to be like
this is where you get in the front seat
next to him stare at him like listen
like the [ __ ] hell
like like like just like [ __ ] because
because like bangkok has like a legit
like a highway so it's like an elevated
highway so we couldn't i couldn't just
tell him to stop
and like and we get another taxi because
we're in the middle of the [ __ ]
highway
so if you're in a [ __ ] japanese taxi
he'll stop on the highway yeah they
don't give a [ __ ] they're crazy here
yeah so basically i i was in it was the
most stressful half-hour ride
i've ever been on sydney was like
stress-free she was asleep she's gonna
hurry
she could have died in the sleep you
know she wasn't the only one who was my
good way to go i mean
yeah i know i was up like [ __ ] pissed
off my mind at 4am being like
trying to have this conversation with
this taxi driver i was like i was i was
just i was just trying to keep him awake
and he was telling me like
oh yeah you know i've got like two kids
away from me at home and i'm just like
dude after this taxi drive go home to
your [ __ ] kids just think about your
kids sleep
for [ __ ] sake please please just think
about your kids right now